to the basket don't expect to hear the  whistle gotta go in there meeting the  score five on the shot clock  DeRozan the turnaround jumper rebound  Charlotte 18 seconds to go shot clock  turned off  Hornets down one Rozier Woodbury Rozier  oh wow at the layup apart Spurs have it  they don't foul to Rosen and the Spurs  are gonna win it Oh father Charlotte  failed to react after the turnover and  the Spurs get the W 104 103  what will it be the next game tell me  congratulations to Timmy Duncan getting  that win that's my boy let me tell you I  mean this shades of Orlando  exactly I mean Orlando you've missed  layup twins in the ball game  Rozier I thought it had the layup there  passed it up oh my so the Spurs start  the three-game road trip with a W and  it'll continue